hello reject family we're about to watch
a second trailer
for the greatest family that has ever
existed
but now there's a cane and able struggle
at
odds a man who was all about family oh
no
must now deal with the consequences of
the
sibling of his actual family actual
blood family blood family this is
fast and furious nine no jokes okay no
jokes
this is the most it's a serious
franchise this is gonna be tough on dom
after everything with his baby in the
last movie oh
baby oh yeah yeah i forgot about that
thing
the world has a way of changing
[Music]
there are foreshadowing that separate us
is it the tokyo drift guy forgot his
name we've come back together
i needed a little love out here huh
[Music]
yeah man who is here jacob is
dumb's brother
my cross is bigger my face and my piety
would you turn your back on me
now your little family
[Music]
i love those shots oh
[Music]
come on he's got to before the trailer's
done
i don't drive
oh my goodness oh my goodness really
upping the hand of hand in this movie
helen mirren
like a reverse magnet or something oh
it's gonna be the
sideways wow
what is this it's good
terrible
to stop that lady on drive over it
come on
oh it's been my entire life in your
shadow
you spend the rest of yours
space travel
come on come on you're doing it
fly that car right through that i mean
you know with the physics and and it
will happen
in the stratosphere going a stupid space
all right where to start with this
they didn't go to space in this trailer
that was smarter than these fast and
furious trailers ruins so much for you
all the time and they're a blast and
they always give you way too many
trailers
uh but they're going to space they got
to be right they're in space
they have two rockets strapped to a
street racing
vehicle and the only imaginable purpose
i could think of for that is to have it
propel them through the stratosphere
which is gonna in real life would burn
that car to a crisp
but you know whoa whoa did you just say
in real life i'm sorry i didn't mean to
invoke
that which we don't speak of maybe with
your family you talk about
real life with this family
no no no no such thing as real that's
right
i take it back yeah that was and i love
how
they've chosen it to be uh tyree skips
and and ludacris
they're the ones
you chose the right ones to go to space
hell yeah
one plus those dudes aren't super huge
either so i feel like that's also going
to help them
you know with not having too much drag i
hope
i hope they actually cause it look like
it's just a tease and this is going to
be the talk
you know because every franchise the
joke is go to space yeah
and fast and furious is the one
franchise like they can
they can do it mm-hmm go to space why
haven't you gone to space yet
they spent the last movie on a plane
with space technology it's only one step
higher
i know right okay so john cena is
definitely gonna become a good guy right
that's everything everything about his
dialogue in this trailer said to me that
this is this
conflict that can be worked out and he
will eventually i mean
join the family it's about family it's
about family
and about forgiveness yeah especially if
it's blood
fast forgiveness furiously forgiveness
fast and furiously forgiving is what's
going to happen the the 10th movie will
be called just fast and at peace
for dominic toretto to be all about
family
and then to have his brother played by
the highly talented wide-ranging
dramatic talent that is john cena
finally bringing some clout to this
series like you don't get an actor like
you
unless you're going to really commit to
a true character
that's cause cypher's in here if cypher
wasn't in here
i might not decipher being in case
people forgot because let's face it a
lot of people are like
who is the rapper cipher no no no i am
talking about charlize theron
uh um cipher's back in here with a new
do
every scene gotta have a new hair cause
she's unrecognizable now
um yeah and uh with cypher being here
and she seems like she's the one who's
kind of manipulating
um uh john cena just a little bit what's
his name jacob
jacob with a k really jacob
it's even a compete in mortal kombat
you have to have the special cave jacob
i think there's going to be a change at
heart it would make more sense than
freaking china
which is insane make four cents
and speaking of jason satan the hobbs i
was thinking about this
uh this morning as i do all mornings
about fast and furious not just because
this trailer came out
is um you know how hobbs and shaw
introduced the sci-fi
superhuman element with uh idris alba
black superman with black superman
rebooted by jj abrams
so with that character i was like well
maybe there's some type of
sci-fi infusion thing with han with his
dna
to bring him back to life i mean that's
i feel like they're rarely gonna do
barely anything to justify it
i can see it absolutely going both ways
i feel like
if you're looking at the series uh
han's death got re-contextualized and
thus more weight and
sort of canonical legitimacy got put on
top of it so i feel like in order to
bring him back they either have to come
up with a
very it's the one place where i will be
like please come up with a good reason
he's
back or they will have some kind of
sci-fi thing going on with him well it
looks like they reinvented his character
a little bit
you remember how he's usually kind of
chill
and eating food he's always just so
relaxed right he's just like the cool
chill guy until like gal gadot was
killed
and i was really sad really sad day
remember
in fast five where she like takes off
her robes she's in a bikini
wow first time we all i can't believe
you're objectifying her wow
the movie did that was how the movie was
telling me to feel
to be fair so he looks more intense this
time around
like there's a little bit of a shady
some humor but his action scenes here
it's a new haircut it's that bucky
barnes effect
you know whenever you take it an actor
who had long hair that you give him that
that crisp haircut yeah definitely i'm
like oh wow
i'm looking in a different light now
that happens haircuts will do that
yeah that's why charlize darren does it
in every scene because she's gotta
change her menace
but yeah no i mean he definitely if he's
coming back from the dead and if he
knows anything about you know
shaw being accepted by the family in any
degree like i can see him having a bit
of a chip you know yeah yeah
and having something to prove i'm
excited justin lin is back that cable
car
pulling scene at the that they had here
in whatever
country so you describe all fast and
furious
whatever european-looking or latin
south american country they're in i
don't know
and then with the roads and the way they
were pulling the cars it was reminding
me a little bit
of when justin lin did reboot fast five
uh with
pulling the vault around that that high
sequence i look cool
i hope this movie is a crisp 80 minutes
yes definitely like i think you get the
impression that this is a solid 80
90 minutes max yeah yeah this is gonna
be one movie it's not gonna be four or
five movies crammed into one movie or
anything like that
it's not gonna try and also be like a
madrapore scene from falcon and winter
soldier or anything like that
what the hell is han doing they're are
they back in mattress mattress
are they back in tokyo it looks like
they're back in tokyo
he's like an assassin now what the hell
is going on here
maybe they go to check some kind of
hinky situation out only to
discover that he is pulling the strings
and then when he's like oh i could have
killed you then that's when they reunite
and then he's like i'm just kidding i'm
happy to see you guys let's let's work
together
oh you got the tokyo drift cast here oh
look out oh damn dang even the the guy
even the driver guy tokyo drift is a
movie that has surprisingly gotten some
love
you know every movie eventually comes
back around especially
as part of a franchise halloween three
people love
now so i'm not surprised tokyo drift is
getting his flower
um but yeah you got a wide variety of
action here that's that's kind of
that's actually what i really like about
this trailer is it there looks like to
be a certain amount of range here
yeah and they didn't lead with only cg
sepia like they led with a lot of stuff
that's like crazy but also you could
achieve with stunts
i hope so well
i says i hope so justin lin it's on you
now it says i hope so
alright guys well fast and furious nine
did you appreciate our easter eggs and
breakdown video
uh subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell
hit that like button do you think this
will be the best one
are you gonna wait for this to come out
on uh some streaming service
fast and furious or never on streaming
never universal has pushed this back
so many times universal is so stingy
yeah man
that's why they they don't let you
monetize i can't put this on peacock
yeah that's not the place to watch fast
why do people from the vr team
at universal email us like try those out
let us know when you cover it
to only be like haha you're not you're
demonetizing we just want to make sure
that we're going to be getting that ad
revenue
so if you could let us know we don't
have to look
[Laughter]
so weird i was over years yeah which one
movie there's a wee insult nah they've
always been that way
stingy bass universal you guys are a
bunch of bastards
yeah marvel lets you say a couple
criticisms yeah they still pay you
yeah it is they give us two thousand
dollars a week yeah
we talk about marvel three times a month
stimulus
anyway the hell are we talking about
um patreon the day shout out
andrew hayes andrew hayes i gotta say
if there's anyone at our patreon who is
all about
family it's andrew hayes he is 45 years
old
and he is still living with his parents
that is dedication to your la familia
yeah man taking over the family business
smithing locks
that is what they do you just
put too much information wow sorry i
don't want people trying to track them
down
and they're gonna threaten your family
and then you're gonna have to like go on
a crazy ass mission with your car
well the thing is is that andrew
actually has
a a twin brother at birth but they
thought he was too ugly oh no
so they just threw him out oh trash
wow but now she wants baby revenge and
andrew's parents don't want him to come
into the family but andrew is like
he's my brother i love him
subconsciously
yeah even though he's a murderer on the
run
from the police andrew you're going to
get yourself killed if you've
decided embark on this relationship with
your long-lost
twin brother yeah donaire andrew
for andrew yeah brand drew's coming for
you and he's pissed all right so you
better find a way to make peace fast
end and
jesus christ job fast and furious and
furious
beef don't be furious when he comes fast
or